le vin ou 2020 alexeï navalni est
victime d'un malaise à bord d'un avion
entre la sibérie et moscou plongé dans
le coma les rapidement transféré en
allemagne où le reprend connaissance
deux semaines plus tard très vite début
septembre un laboratoire militaire
allemand conclu à l'empoisonnement de
l'opposant russe à l'aide d'un agents
neurotoxiques de type nos vies de choc
une conclusion cependant quelque peu
hâtive aux yeux de moscou
on a le sentiment d'assister à une
situation où malheureusement au lieu
d'une enquête approfondie un travail
commun assidus dont le but doit être
l'obtention d'un résultat juste nos
partenaires préfèrent des déclarations
publiques et régulière sans présenter
aucun fait
d'autant que pour en arriver à ce
diagnostic
les autorités allemandes se sont fait
aider de loyat c'est l'organisation pour
l'interdiction des armes chimiques en la
russie s'interroge sur des éléments
troublants concernant un rapport de cet
organisme qui stipule que l'allemagne a
demandé que lui soit envoyé une équipe
d'experts le 20 août le jour même du
malaise à l'excès navalni deux jours
avant son arrivée à berlin jours plus
tard le jass et corrige le rapport et
remplace la date du 20 août par celle du
4 septembre plaidant l'erreur technique
dès sa sortie du coma alexeï navalni
s'exprime et pour lui aucun doute le
kremlin est directement responsable de
ce qu'il considère être un
empoisonnement
poutine derrière le crime et je n'ai pas
d'autre version du déroulement des
événements l'ordre de tuer navalni a été
limitée au plus haut niveau et celui
d'utiliser ou de produire le novice choc
ne peut venir que de trois hommes le
chef du fsb le chef du service de
renseignement étranger le svr où le chef
du g et rue
ces derniers ne peuvent prendre une
telle décision sans une instruction de
poutine et lui sont subordonnés
rapidement l'union européenne et les
etats unis demandent des comptes à
moscou de leur côté les autorités russes
se plaignent de ne pas avoir accès aux
données des allemands pour pouvoir
répondre aux accusations le président
russe a lui aussi répondu aux
accusations internationales et a démenti
toute tentative d'empoisonnement le
patient de la clinique berlinoise
bénéficie de l'appui des services
spéciaux américains et si c'est ainsi
alors c'est intéressant et il doit être
surveillé par les services spéciaux bien
sûr mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
l'empoisonner qui auraient besoin de
cela vous voyez en tout cas si nous
l'avions voulu la faire aurait été menée
à son terme quoi qu'il en soit
l'opposant russe finit par se rétablir
et décide de revenir en russie le 17
janvier il atterri à moscou où il est
interpellé peu après son atterrissage en
cause ses violations répétées des
conditions d'une peine de prison avec
sursis pour détournement de fonds deux
semaines plus tard la justice russe
traduit cette sentence en trois ans et
demi de prison ferme - les mois que
l'opposant avait déjà passé assigné à
résidence
alexeï navalni a violé à plusieurs
reprises les conditions de sa peine de
prison assortis de sursis 10 fois en
2018 40 fois en 2019 et s'il faut en
2020 soit les 13 et 27 janvier 3 février
16 mars 6 juillet 17 août 2000 dans
l'arrestation de l'opposant provoque une
vague de manifestations à travers le
pays ces rassemblements ne sont pas
autorisés et entraîne de nombreuses
interpellations le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères regrette pour sa
part la couverture médiatique
occidentale des manifestations
en couvrant les événements qui se
déroulent en russie on montre presque
seulement la réaction de la police face
aux actes des manifestants sans même
montré ses actes alors qu'il est facile
de constater sur internet le caractère
agressif des actes de ceux qui ont
participé ces derniers jours aux
manifestations illégales à moscou et
dans d'autres villes de russie
la russie expulse également trois
diplomates un allemand un suédois et un
polonais accusés d'avoir participé un de
ces rassemblements non autorisés
trois jours plus tard les trois pays
concernés renvoie à leur tour chacun un
diplomate russe dans la continuité début
mars plusieurs pays occidentaux adoptent
des sanctions contre des responsables et
entités russes pour leur implication
présumée dans la sphère navalni
représailles moscou interdit à son tour
l'entrée sur son territoire à plusieurs
hauts responsables de l'union européenne
la justice russe a interdit quant à elle
plusieurs organisation fondée par alexeï
navalni accusé de tentative de
déstabilisation et d'activités
extrémistes et d'ailleurs face au risque
d'emprisonnement plusieurs soutiens
proche de l'opposant russe ont quitté le
pays ces derniers mois en définitive que
ce soit au sujet de son empoisonnement
présumés ou de son arrestation à son
retour l'opposant russe cristallise à
lui seul tensions et des accords entre
la russie et l'occident